Повсюди у світі однакова картина.
Байдуже, Північна чи Південна Америка, Європа, Африка, Азія чи Австралія.
Повсюди затори. І так вже десятиліттями.
Часом менше машин, часом більше.
Немає значення - право- чи лівосторонній рух. І головне - ніхто не знає, ЧОМУ?
Разом з тим є дороги, на яких ніколи не буває заторів.
Це мурашині дороги. Тут рух тече без жодних перешкод.
Чому поведінка мурах на дорогах настільки краща за нашу?
Можливо, в них не лише поведінка краща, але вони й водії кращі, ніж ми?
Ми вирушаємо на пошуки, потрапляємо в затор і говоримо з експертами.
Кожен із нас колись стояв у заторах і думав: Дідько!
Це взагалі ніяке не задоволення.
Як би там не було, ми страждаємо не одні.
Я свідомо в'їжджаю у затор - з наукових міркувань.
Це не дуже допомагає, адже кожен, хто стоїть у заторі, роздратований, хіба ні?
Я щасливий, коли стою у заторі. Чого моя дружина взагалі не розуміє.
Мурашки, звісно ж, теж не розуміють, що роблять люди у своїх машинах.
І чому вони постійно застрягають у заторах? Мурашки ні з чим подібним не стикаються.
Вони інші. Але що саме вони роблять інакше?
Мурашки - це комахи, які створюють державу і мають свого роду соціальну систему
з різними професіями та різними функціями. Вони працюють спільно
як команда і спільно долають проблеми.
Мурашки постійно в русі. Але їхній робочий ритм - безперебійний. У чому секрет?
У мурашок усе функціонує, тому що в них справді одна спільна мета.
Вони прагнуть швидко розбудувати мурашину державу.
Люди теж мають спільну мету: якомога швидше потрапити з пункту А в пункт Б.
Але в цьому вони постійно зазнають невдач.
А чи знаєте ви, де фіксують найдовші затори?
Третє місце: від урагану Рита 21 вересня 2005 року
з Хьюстона тікали два з половиною мільйони людей.
У напрямку Далласа утворився затор довжиною 160 кілометрів,
рух зупинився на 48 годин.
Друге місце: фінал чемпіонату світу з футболу в Бразилії.
Затор брав початок ще у Сан-Паоло і простягнувся на 344 км.
Тобто майже на всю відстань між Сан-Паоло і Ріо.
Перше місце: Москва у листопаді 2012-го.
Російська зима стала причиною найдовшого затору в історії.
Три дні і три ночі магістраль між Санкт-Петербургом і Москвою
була повністю в полоні снігу.
Інші рекорди та цифри ми наведемо пізніше.
Спершу з'ясуємо, що таке затор!
Отже, коли у плинному дорожньому русі виникає затор?
Я би описав затор як ситуацію, в якій окремі транспортні засоби
мусять зупинитися на певний час. Тобто на кілька секунд або більше.
Але в заторі також є рух, внутрішня швидкість якого становить
приблизно 10 кілометрів на годину.
Головна причина - нестача місця.
Бувають і інші причини, але не так часто.
Деякі люди, приміром, роблять помилки у водінні,
коли вони не уважні і мусять раптово гальмувати.
Я би ще додала, що причиною заторів можуть бути ремонтні роботи на дорогах та ДТП. Але що ще?
Ремонтні роботи, ДТП, погана погода…
Але 60-70 відсотків усіх заторів - залежно від регіону -
виникають через перевантаженість доріг: надто багато автомобілів в однаковий час
рухаються в однаковому напрямку.
Власне, всюди одна й та сама причина, майже всюди у світі!
Ок, то що ми, люди, можемо запозичити у поведінці мурашок?
У мурашок справді головний принцип: один за всіх - всі за одного.
Чого у водіїв часто явно бракує. Бо кожен думає: як я найшвидше досягну
кінцевої цілі? Через те, що кожен окремо намагається проштовхнути свої інтереси
та не зважає на інтереси інших.
Мурашки дуже кооперативні. Вони не блокують одне одного,
оскільки усі вони працюють над досягненням однієї мети.
Вони хочуть доставити їжу в мурашник, заради цього вони працюють спільно.
Що відрізняється від поведінки нормального водія в умовах нормального дорожнього руху.
Водії на дорогах не є кооперативними.
Вони егоїстичні, і це заважає системі в цілому функціонувати ефективно.
Ми маємо різні - говорячи мовою математики - максимуми.
Існує один оптимум для окремого користувача і інший оптимум для системи.
Водій прагне для себе особисто використати свій максимум,
але для системи це не найкращий спосіб поведінки в тій чи іншій ситуації.
І якщо водії працюють один проти одного, то система як така не функціонує ефективно.
Наскільки повільніше тече дорожній рух,
вже порахували виробники навігаційних систем.
Здається, фірма Tom-Tom провела дослідження і вирахувала,
наскільки більше часу потребують люди в дорозі на роботу в години пік.
Для Берліна цей показник становить 30%. Це означає, що в ідеальних умовах,
приміром, опівночі, можна доїхати за 20 хвилин. У години пік - плюс 30%,
це буде приблизно 26 хвилин.
Хоча мешканцю Берліна, мабуть, здається, що насправді він простоює у заторах значно довше.
12 квітня 1990 року цей показник був, безперечно, у кілька разів вищий.
Тоді у заторах застрягли мільйони автівок, у напрямку схід-захід.
Таким є німецький рекорд. Це були перші великодні
канікули після падіння Берлінського муру.
Назад у сьогодення.
Берлін з відривом - найбільше місто Німеччини.
Однак у світовому порівнянні берлінські затори - смішні.
Погляньмо на топ-3 міста світу з найбільшими заторами.
На третьому місці - Богота.
Мешканці колумбійської столиці у середньому простоюють у заторах 230 годин на рік.
Тобто майже 10 днів! У декого зриває дах…
На 2-му місці – індійський мегаполіс Бангалор -
цілих 243 години на рік водії стояли тут у заторах у 2019-му.
І очолює світовий антирейтинг філіппінська столиця Маніла -
у середньому 257 годин на рік водії проводять у заторах.
Люди купують машини, бо хочуть швидко дістатися з точки А в точку Б.
Але що коли це не вдається?
Люди змінюються, щойно вони сідають у машину.
Вони стають геть іншими особистостями!
Навіть якщо в своєму приватному оточенні ти - найприязніша людина у світі,
в машині ти перетворюється на чудовисько.
Ми маємо дуже багато проблем з 10% водіїв,
які поводять себе агресивно на дорогах.
Власне, вони і є причиною багатьох заторів.
Дехто говорить про повну моральну деградацію. Але що це означає?
Багато людей мають дуже-дуже щільний графік.
І коли вони потрапляють у затор, з яким вони не рахувалися, ці люди розлючуються.
У своїх авто вони анонімні, ніхто не знає їхнього імені.
І тому вони роблять на дорогах речі,
які за інших обставин ніколи не зробили б.
Затори - це чистий стрес, хіба ні?
Вони спричиняють свого роду емоційну вразливість.
Але деякі люди саме цього й шукають…
Тобто вони люблять цей адреналін…
Я - ні!
Машина - це певною мірою твій особистий простір,
як і твоя домівка. Тобто це ніби розширення твого житла.
І цей простір ніхто не повинен порушувати.
50 см відстані - це важлива межа. Якщо чужі авто наближаються
на меншу дистанцію, людина починає злитися на інших водіїв.
Так, нам не подобається, коли інші водії надто підтискають нас.
Так само, як і не подобається, коли чужі люди вилуплюються у вікна наших домівок.
А як мурашкам вдається дотримуватися необхідної відстані?
Мурашки комунікують через запахи, позаду вони мають спеціальні залози.
Вони можуть змішувати запахи, передаючи інформацію.
Приміром: Увага, небезпека! Тут їжа! Рухатися сюди!
Мурашки є кращими водіями,
оскільки вони кооперують. Вони працюють на благо спільноти,
вони прагнуть якнайкращого для цілої системи.
Вони не хочуть комусь заважати у цьому робочому плині.
І цьому ми можемо в них повчитися.
Але я сумніваюся, що людей можна навчити поводитися так, як мурашки.
Звісно, усе було б простіше, якби ми, люди, не були такими складними:
Чи знали ви, що за кермом сидять 7 різних типів особистості?
Каратель, конкурент, вчитель, філософ, уникач, всезнайко та втікач.
Про це трохи згодом… А зараз назад у затор!
Скільки коштує затор?
Як я вже казав, внутрішня швидкість затору - 10 кілометрів на годину.
Тож, приміром, ми маємо 4-кілометровий затор на автобані, на двох смугах,
який триває 3 години. І ти можеш їхати лише 10 замість 80 кілометрів на годину.
Тоді можна вирахувати, скільки коштує втрачений час усіх, хто стояв у цьому заторі -
десь між 50 тисячами і 100 тисячами євро.
Вау!
Лише ОДИН затор! Я порахував для цілої Німеччини у рік -
виходить 60-100 мільярдів євро!
Візьмемо середню цифру - 80 млрд євро щорічно коштує німцям
простоювання у заторах. Тобто ми втрачаємо у заторах не лише час, а й гроші.
Інше дослідження – про дорожній рух у США -
вирахувало схожі цифри. Але при цьому з'ясували ще дещо:
водії свідомо уникають найшвидших маршрутів.
З тієї причини, що вони платні.
Водії роблять вибір на користь зекономлених грошей, а не зекономленого часу.
Схожі результати підтвердили також інші дослідження, де йшлося про розмір плати
за проїзд автобаном. Більшість водіїв не були готові витрачати
більше грошей на так звані швидкісні смуги.
А чи відомо, власне, скільки часу німці щорічно безглуздо простоюють у заторах?
Німецькими дорогами щороку долають 500 млрд кілометрів.
З них багато кілометрів люди стоять у заторах.
Якщо підбити все докупи - близько 530 000 років - щороку!
Отже, підсумуємо: 500 млрд км проїжджають німецькими дорогами на рік.
Сонце розташоване на відстані 150 млн км.
Тобто за грубими підрахунками німці за рік проїздять
3300 разів до Сонця - у машині!
Ще божевільнішим виглядає те, що усі ми разом щороку стоїмо у пробках
530 тисяч років. Вражає, чи не так?
Навіть якщо поділити це на 58 млн зареєстрованих у Німеччині машин.
Утім, мурашок значно більше. І їм все вдається. То у чому їхніх секрет?
Чому мурашки мають кращі звички на дорогах?
По-перше, вони рухаються не так швидко. Це означає, якщо трапляється ДТП,
то це приблизно так, ніби зіткнулися дві людини,
нічого драматичного при цьому не стається.
Тому вони можуть пересуватися значно щільніше одна до одної.
Тоді як машини потребують значно більше дистанції одна від одної, аби дотримуватися безпеки.
Мурашки мають свого роду систему раннього сповіщення.
Це успадковувалося від покоління в покоління, тобто є чимось природним,
на рівні інстинкту. А у людей усе вирішується через якісь технічні рішення.
У майбутньому ми будемо мати автоматичні системи,
які зможуть копіювати поведінку мурашок.
І сподіваюся, врешті-решт ми отримаємо функціонуючу ефективну
дорожньо-транспортну систему, яка матиме більші обсяги, ніж нинішня.
Тож, завдяки мурашкам людство може розвинути
кращу техніку дорожнього руху. Можливо, ми також навчимося
кращому ставленню одне до одного.